People Are Not Mere products products
don't have rights people do babies
included in fact it is precisely because
babies have rights that adults cannot
claim to have a right to them many
people today fall into the error of
believing that they have a right to a
child even some conservatives fall into
this error but it's Preposterous in
making that claim actually they
undermine their own argument because if
people have any rights at all then no
one can have a right to another person a
child is not something that is owed to
someone but rather a child is a blessing
a gift that one is given a child is the
Supreme gift of marriage